[Music]
now
vaccination may have been opened up to
16 year olds now
but the government is still facing a
problem with lack of vaccine
uptake in younger age groups now in an
attempt to weigh 20 somethings after
telling them they'll be banned from
nightclubs and maybe their university
lectures too
the government is promising discounts
with uber and delivery as bribes
will it work i'm joined by rory
sutherland the spectator's wikiman
columnist
and vice chairman at the advertising
agency ogilvy
rory thanks for joining spectator tv
what do you reckon do you think this is
going to work
they probably will work i'm very
skeptical generally about mainstream
economics
but i wouldn't be so extreme as to say
that incentives don't work
um and those are you know those are
fairly well targeted benefits
um other interesting behavioral
scientists have also looked at the
effect of lotteries
on encouraging vaccination which is
particularly if you design a lottery in
such a way that you might end up being a
winner but knowing that you missed out
through failing to vaccinate yourself
those can also be quite powerful
incentives to encourage people
to take up a behavior when they're what
you might call on the margin
looking at this uber and delivery
discount i was a bit peeved that i've
actually already had my first job i've
got my second jab already booked in
maybe i should just delayed because my
compliance is not really being rewarded
well there is always the risk that
people game the system
a little bit or that people might
actually hold off on vaccination
waiting for a higher offer rather like
those people who refuse to sell their
house to a developer
on the grounds that if they're the last
person resisting
they'll get the best price i mean i
would argue that
some to some degree it's fair to say of
younger people
that the impetus to be vaccinated if
you're 25
is not the same impetus if you're 55.
because the the the likelihood of
fatality
is minimal from kovid um
and so it's a more pro-social act
becoming vaccinated if you're young
whereas if you're older you could argue
well to some degree it's a selfish act
and therefore uh the engagement of some
sort of
additional incentive or encouragement
for young people
of course it won't work on complete
anti-vaxxers it only works at the
margins
but then if you think about it
epidemiology kind of works at the
margins
in other words you don't need absolutely
everybody to be vaccinated
uh in order for uh this thing to be
killed
you just need a sufficiently high
proportion of people to effectively
bring the r rate below one
and so uh it is important to say that
you know if you can do something via
persuasion
my my favorite methods uh of approaching
a problem are
first of all try persuading people then
if that fails try bribing people
and only if that fails should you ever
consider compulsion
now the strange thing about government
is it's dominated by lawyers who
occasionally take advice from economists
and government tends to approach things
from legislation first
inducement or financial incentive second
and persuasion third
now whatever the relative merits of
those three interventions and there's a
kind of temperamental libertarian
um i always favor persuasion wherever
possible
i don't think it's difficult to make the
case that government often approaches
those things in the wrong order
what do you think persuasion looks like
in this context
when it comes to covid um i saw a german
advert last year for example
uh asking young people to stay at home
during lockdown and comparing
their efforts to their grandparents
efforts in second world war and you know
giving them sort of
heroicism to the thing i thought that
was i thought that was a brilliant thing
which
without mentioning the second world war
explicitly
okay what it effectively said is you
know in the past and i have made that i
don't know if i made that argument
in a similar way beforehand i said
americans are going completely bananas
about wearing masks
but i would argue that compared to being
forced to fight in the tet offensive
okay or go into the jungle being shot at
by the vietcong
i would argue that wearing a mask down
the high street of moline
is a relatively small inconvenience to
have to endure
and then the germans took this same
framing and did it rather brilliantly
which more or less said
it it had an elderly person effectively
in the future
talking about their service and it was
contrasting implicitly the difference
between being able to fight
being forced to fight the ivans on the
eastern front and merely staying at home
ordering pizzas watching netflix
and it was incredibly funny and charming
and i think
it was all the more persuasive because
it was humorous i think one of the
things that the germans managed to do
which
interestingly maybe the british didn't
was partly to use a little bit of humor
now we know you know historically humor
is a magical means just as music is in a
sense
for generating an emotional state
without some of the negatives that arise
if you try and use the sheer brute force
of reason
and you can make points humorously which
are then accepted which would be
rejected if you tried to make them in
deadly seriousness and so i thought the
germans
deserve a significant commendation for
how they handled it
and it seemed to have worked um but um
i i think it is important to remember
that many many things and i'd include
that
things like adoption of electric cars
okay we don't need everybody to adopt
electric cars
forcing people or bribing people to
adopt electric cars
unfairly punishes a lot of people who
bite into their circumstances
can't or won't adopt them so persuasion
should always be the first mode of
intervention
simply because it harvests the
low-hanging fruit
and sometimes the low-hanging fruit is
all you need
you know i've i've argued for ages it's
just an environmental policy look if you
encourage people to put their tumble
dryers and washing machines on later at
night
okay um that will actually reduce carbon
emissions simply because the uk is kind
of nuclear powered or powered heavily by
renewables
at 10 o'clock in the evening in a way
that it isn't at five o'clock
now if you try to make that compulsory
or you use the price mechanism
what happens to people who work the
night shift they can't do it
you don't want them leaving their house
with a tumble dryer on what happens to
people who live in a flat
and their washing machine is immediately
above their neighbor's bedroom
which means it's going to hit the spin
cycle at one o'clock in the morning
those people can't do it now the great
thing with persuasion is if you've got a
good reason
you can advance that reason and you're
now immune
or freed from the obligation the second
you start using economic incentives or
legal uh
legal directives that nuance gets
completely lost
and you try and design legislation for
everybody which in some cases ends up
working for nobody
and we've only really seen that
persuasion you know you've had people
like gareth southgate
making a short video asking young people
to get vaccinated but
i've not really heard anything else
really in that persuasion side
on the other hand we have heard about
vaccine passports being coming in for
nightclubs under the thought that under
30s go to nightclubs and
this is what's going to get them to get
get jabbed what do you make of that we
had some
so mark warport who is um patrick
valenz's predecessor in the chief
scientific advisor role
on spectator tv recently and he was
calling that a nudge
i mean it feels more like a shelf yes
the vaccine passport of course it's
it's it's ambiguous in a way in that
you know i i mean the way i describe
myself is a is a default libertarian i
don't
i don't accept the idea that there
aren't coordination problems i don't
accept the idea that there isn't a need
for
uh central uh um i i don't object you
know to put it very simply i don't
object to people painting lines in the
car park
okay you know there are certain you know
you know if you're an extreme
libertarian you'd say it's interfering
with my right to park at the diagonal
i don't object to that kind of thing you
know
painting white lines on the road is a
nudge if you like
okay and you know even deirdre mccloskey
who's more libertarian i think than i am
argues that there are there's a large
informational role that government can
play
which needn't involve any kind of
compulsion at all now
where does the issuing of a passport
where it's up to the private sector to
determine whether they require that
passport or not
where does that sit now to me
personally and i admit this is very very
subjective to me that's relatively
uncontroversial if the passport is being
policed by private entities
who simply say sorry it's our restaurant
if you're not prepared to do this
you can't come in when it becomes
employers for example or academic
institutions you know
novak no no vaxx no lecture that gets a
bit more contentious
because you can argue well you don't
necessarily have free choice there
you know you don't you can't suddenly
switch university according to their
vaccine policy and so it's complicated i
generally regard the imposition of
vaccine rules um
by private institutions as broadly
speaking acceptable
it gets more contentious um if you like
when it it starts to be imposed in areas
where
i would i would argue that um
mark squaring you know i i don't really
understand the massive
descent over masks because to me you
know there are plenty of inconvenient
things like wearing underpants that i do
really you know not you know not
necessarily for my own self-interest but
simply to avoid alarming other people
and i would i would place mask wearing
in the field of courtesy
which is even if you don't believe in
them and i think they do work by the way
you know i think at some level they
undoubtedly work
but even if you don't believe in them
some people do
and it's deeply you know discourteous to
elderly people who may be alarmed by
someone
uh wandering around the shops without a
mask i think it's simply an act of
courtesy
to other people and you know it also
sits within i think you know the
reasonable realm of
um the precautionary principle you know
well this might work and generally the
cost-benefit
uh thing looks fairly high when you're
demanding people
um are vaccinated who are young
for example and there are side effects
to the vaccine
among the young you know they're you
know they're not particularly unpleasant
for the most part
but they're not negligible i'm getting a
bit more uncomfortable there and i might
also raise the question well
what if to be honest it isn't necessary
to hit 100
and rory just on that vaccine passport
point some people have been saying that
because it's coming in in september
not immediately that actually all of it
is just a ploy for people to get
vaccinated and come september
these passports may not even come into
place
but what i wonder about that is that
isn't it quite a hit on the government's
credibility
to do that kind of u-turn to kind of
dangle this kind of threat over young
people and then rescinded as if they
never wanted to do it in the first place
i mean
that credibility hit surely in the minds
of people is actually not insignificant
well it's a very interesting question
isn't it which is how should we react
to legislation which is
really exists for its signaling value
rather than
as an actual restraint on behavior
so it acts as an accelerant it
encourages people to act fast it's
equivalent to
only four seats left at this price which
is you might as well do it now because
you'll have to do it ultimately
now as you might expect working in the
advertising industry with a strong
interest in kind of behavioral science
um legislation that i mean actually
quite a lot of legislation in a way
works that way
i mean we don't impose speed limits uh
rigorously okay we you know we we very
rarely find people for going
um 73 miles an hour and so legislation
which
uh which which exists in potential but
isn't necessarily
uh enforced can have a value because it
essentially
it you know it might accelerate a
behavior it might um
it may might make corporate decision
making easier because you can say this
is going to be a legal requirement in
five years time
so we might as well start acting now all
our competitors will be doing this
so in solving coordination problems um
laws which act to send a message
rather than to actually necessarily be
enforced i would argue
actually from a libertarian point of
view fairly desirable
in a funny kind of way because they
solve the coordination problem
without necessarily limiting liberty
and so the way i always phrase it is i'm
not a pure libertarian but i'm glad such
people exist
because i think that mentality uh plays
an essential component
part in looking at decision-making
over how government intervenes with the
populace
i'm i'm not massively sympathetic
towards anti-masters because it seems to
be a very very small price to pay
and it seems to be a slightly deranged
fear anti-vaxxers
i would seek if possible because you
know there are potential arguments
against universal vaccination
um and anti-vaxxers in that case i would
seek to find an accommodation with them
rory sutherland thanks for joining
spectator tv
[Music]
you